so one of our unbending life rules is
don't get involved in things you don't
understand
don't take sides in arguments
you don't really get um
but we violate it all the time of course
because sometimes something really
interesting happens and you just have to
kind of wait and see what it's about
that's exactly what's happening in golf
right now and as we should just say at
the outset we're not taking sides in
this but one of the biggest
controversies in sports in many years is
taking place between the pga tour
and an upstart tour called live
now we watched this hap we didn't know
exactly what to make of it but it seemed
interesting
lots of drama in one of america's top
sports a sport with a storied history so
we decided to go to trump bedminster the
golf club yesterday in new jersey
and find out what was happening while
there we talked one of the best golfers
in the history of sport who's now the
commissioner of live
international and asked him why are you
doing this exactly that would be greg
norman who's part of a conversation with
him
what is the business model i mean you're
you're not signing your players to an
exclusivity contract at all they can
play
wherever else they want
there are no tv rights at this point
you're streaming it for free
they're putting a huge amount of money
into it that's obvious just from sitting
here
so how does the revenue arrive
well the revenue will come in once we
launched the league right this year is a
startup yes
because
quite honestly back in february when we
were ready to start up there was a few
obstacles thrown in our way from the pga
tour and so we had to pull our
reins back a little bit for our viewers
who aren't following you can you give us
a sense of those obstacles well that's
when the book came out about phil
mickelson there was some phil mickelson
made some not so complimentary remarks
about
the saudi saudi where the money came
from and saudi arabia and then the
snowballs and created a bit of a
domino's or a scary effect and the pga
tour came in and they obviously did the
right thing and trying to protect their
monopoly came in and the players backed
off a little bit
so we had to regroup we're ready to sign
the next week we're ready to sign
multiple players and launch the league
so we decided to take a step back
analyze the situation and we knew our
model was where it was we knew our
investor was still there he wasn't going
anywhere the money was in the bank
right so we just made an adjustment and
we worked around every obstacle that's
been thrown in our path so we came up
with the invitational series the beta
test
less right now with the fans tucker
we did a survey for nearly 12 months
around the world asking
fans from different tours
what are they like and what are they
missing
and they came up
it was overwhelmingly
more fan engagement right more fan
experiences
and team sport
give us more teams and that's we built
the model around that and our model
tucker is
100
built around the golf ecosystem from the
ground up
so we're not trying to just destroy the
pga tour or the european tour we're
there to work within the ecosystem to
show that it's big enough space it's a
multi-billion dollar industry right
billions of billions of dollars in the
game of golf why would sponsors drop
golfers for participating and live
tucker that blows my mind and sponsors
by the way who spend billions of dollars
in saudi arabia
the pga tour
that's a good point right can you give
us examples i'll give you a prime
example the pga tour i think has about
27 sponsors
on the pga tour do 40 plus billion
dollars worth of business on an annual
basis in saudi arabia
now why doesn't the pga tour call the
ceos of each one of those organizations
sorry we can't do business with you
because you're doing business with saudi
arabia
why are they picking on the professional
golfers
why the male professional golfers
females the lpga tour is sponsored by
aramco
right literally literally the largest
sponsor of women's golf in the world is
a ramp cup
that not one word has been said about
them right but why is it why is it on
the guys why are we the ogres what have
we done wrong
we're independent contractors we have a
right to go play wherever we want in the
world
for whatever we want so what do you
think that's clearly not about principle
obviously so what is it about it's a
monopoly they just want to shut us down
whatever way they can right so they'll
use whatever leverage point they can to
shut us down and they're not
they're not going to shut us down
because the product's speaking for
itself we have
my phone um almost on a daily basis gets
calls every day from players one in i
want in can i how can i join live can it
i tell them i'm sorry the shop is closed
so the list gets longer and longer
longer for the players who want to come
in
which again it's a testament to
the the right white noise why is it so
offensive to some american golf fans
that you're doing this what are they mad
about do you i don't know i really don't
care quite honestly i just love the game
of golf so much and i just want to grow
the game of golf and
and we at live see that opportunity we
live see it not just for the men but for
the women we live here for ncaa and
younger generations we live see it as a
pathway to opportunities for these kids
to experience a new world out there
live is the future of golf
and it's in more it's just that's a very
simple phrase and comment but is liv is
the future of golf because you have you
don't see what we see in the future you
don't see what we want to invest in the
future csr programs education programs
all this stuff that's out there that we
want to get involved with for golf and
growing the game of golf so you keep
reading that you offered tiger woods
seven 800 billion dollars some unknown
number to join live is that true
that number was out there before i
became ceo
so that number's been out there yes yeah
and look it tight as a needle mover
right yeah so of course you're gonna
look at the best of the best you know so
um
they had originally approached tiger
before i became ceo so yes that number
is somewhere in that neighborhood
big number
yeah it is actually i would say call me
small time what's donald trump's
connection he seems like a supporter we
haven't talked about it but he i mean
we're at his golf club right now i've
known donald for a long time i've played
golf with him before he was president um
and i've done golf courses that he's
bought he's acquired right
so
his passion for the game of golf is as
passionate as as he's being a president
where stars and stripes throw flow
through his blood right he's same with
golf he loves his golf and he sees the
commercial opportunity of what golf can
give him right
but trump ben minister is no different
right the membership here is full
it's a it's a commercial entity for him
it's an operation where he can you can
make some revenue out of it
so when we first started um obviously as
the starter we needed
venues he had heard about it we were in
discussions with him
and we just negotiated a
venue fee with him here and he loved it
and he's now in this week he's just been
in the background but in the foreground
if you know what i mean yeah
so he's been fantastic this week he
doesn't he's not
putting himself out in front of liv
he's embraced it
he walks to the first tee uh he allows
liv
to breathe
which i think is fantastic
and i've been with him every day and
it's an opportunity for us because
they're great venues the players love
this place it's a great opportunity for
us to showcase i just went up there
and i would just walk through with 600
members through in the member section of
the clubhouse
and
you cannot
believe the
the thank yous and the energy and
appreciate what you've done here for
this organization i've never seen our
boss so happy you know golf is this and
you've done this for bedminster and we
really really do thank you for it
it's just incredible it's i mean that
from a ceo commissioner standpoint
it's it's exhausting sometimes to go
around 600 people and and do that but
it's so rewarding to hear the feedback
from it it actually re-energizes me
right and uh so i just did that before
coming to see you
rick norman thank you thank you tiger
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight